[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday November
30th Hank I'm not gonna sit here and lie
to you it's 12:30 in the afternoon and
I'm still wearing my jammy pants Hank
I've always believed that a man who
works from home is entitled to one day
in his jammy pants per week
Hank today's video comes in two parts
part one is very short part two is very
long part one the happy dance project
Hank I was supposed to finish the happy
dance project by December first but
guess what
I'm not going to sorry life is hard and
full of disappointment instead of
finishing it by December I'm going to
finish it in December but Hank I can
make this promise to the nerdfighters
there will be a happy dance project and
it will change your life part to
Christmas Hank in the last couple weeks
you spent some time railing against the
commercialization of Christmas and as
you know I am also opposed to Christmas
I mean I like the religious holiday but
I don't like anything about the secular
side of it I don't like Santa Claus who
was invented by the same guy who
invented Uncle Sam and I can totally see
the connection because basically Santa
Claus is all like I need you to spend
more money on consumer goods in December
by the way I don't like Uncle Sam either
I find him pervy I don't like mixing the
colors red and green I don't think they
match also the Christmas lights Hank I
just don't get it
putting Christmas lights outside of your
house is like saying I don't think that
electricity is a valuable resource
I don't like reindeer they seem like
regular deer only more dangerous
I don't like elves unless they are
played by Liv Tyler and I really don't
like toy soldiers toy soldiers freak me
out I mean Hank if you think about it if
the toy soldiers and the elves got
together there would be no stopping them
I mean the toy soldiers would have no
problem hijacking Santa's sleigh the
elves could put lead paint in all of our
toys and then we'd have a group of
extremely well armed soldiers using a
flying sleigh to attack us and we
wouldn't be able to defend ourselves
because all the web poisoning made us
stupid oh my god Hank it's an
apocalyptic scenario
I don't like eggnog if I want to eat
eggs I want to eat eggs and if I want to
drink I want to drink but I don't want
to do both at the same time I think it's
weird to take a dead tree and put it
inside your house and covered in lights
that could catch fire
I do like Christmas ornaments that is
the one secularized thing about
Christmas I like Hank I don't want to
sound like some kind of religious
fundamentalist who thinks there was a
golden era in human history that we need
to go back to but my
basic rule about Christmas is this I
like everything about Christmas that was
thought up before the Year 1800 that
said if everyone felt the way I did
there would be a worldwide recession and
our economy would collapse so I think
those are my thoughts on Christmas I am
buying some gifts this year but it's for
kids I don't know who need clothes and
maybe that should be the policy you only
give gifts to people who need gifts
anyway Hank /rant I'll see you tomorrow
nerdfighters no clue this weekend
instead head to my pants and help us
solve our identity crisis